[Musique]
je vous présente aujourd'hui la
résidence Athéna
cette résidence étudiante elle est sans
doute une génération nouvelle de
bâtiments des bâtiments qui sont
décarbonés d'abord
qui visent une grande biodiversité dans
la conception ce grand jardin nous
permet aussi de faire un recueil des
eaux pluviales à la parcelle de recréer
de la biodiversité dans ce lieu central
on l'a un peu conçu comme un avis c'est
un grand bateau il fait plus de 120
mètres de long et 13 mètres de large et
il y aura 300 étudiants hébergés là dans
des cabines alors pas comme des cabines
de bateaux puisque la conception est un
peu particulière c'est une série
d'appartements donc il y a 300 plus de
300 hébergements et qui sont regroupés
en une quarantaine de d'appartements
donc chaque appartement 2 à 2 dans une
système de grandes courses de coursive
vertical
regroupe une grande une grande terrasse
commune qu'on a appelé un plongeoir qui
t'emballe con sur ce grand jardin à
l'ouest dans lequel ils pourront
échanger
la deuxième caractéristique c'est que ce
qui en fait un paquebot et une sorte de
grande croisière c'est qu'ils ont plus
de 500 mètres carrés d'espace partagé
essentiellement localisé au
rez-de-chaussée donc dans sa conception
c'est un bâtiment qui est construit
majoritairement en bois ce qui fait son
son fameux bilan carbone il est
entièrement conçu on le voit avec un
système de poteau poutre bois et ensuite
des planchers en béton
il est à la fois construit en bois et en
béton est très préfabriqué c'est à dire
que c'est des éléments qui arrivent
monter pour la plupart ils sont
assemblés ici rapidement ça ça baisse
aussi le niveau de disons de de
nuisances qu'on impose à un lieu qui est
déjà très habité et en même temps c'est
le c'est le système qui nous permet
d'avoir une vraie qualité constructive
la particularité de bâtiment c'est qu'on
a implanté de manière très très économe
sur le sur la parcelle on a plus de 60%
de la parcelle qui nous était dévolué
qui a été rendu en pleine terre boisé
qui nous permet d'infiltrer de l'eau et
de se limiter dans sa phase constructive
donc il y a ce côté très frugal dans son
implantation sur le site ça je pense que
c'est aussi une des caractéristiques
importantes de ce lieu on est implanté
dans un lieu qui est absolument
magnifique qui est boisé qui est déjà
constitué qu'on voulait préserver
absolument dans son identité dans sa
force et je pense que demain ce lieu va
devenir un lieu assez festif pour les
étudiants et en même temps très
qualitatif dans la qualité de vie
[Musique]